[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
July 13th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
any of us have an internal timeline that
dictates by what age we should get
promoted at work or buy a home or get
married wsj work and life columnist
Rachel feinsick is here to discuss why
it might make sense to toss those
preconceived notions aside so Rachel you
mean we can escape the shackles of the
adage time has passed me by many of us
are still kind of plagued by the weight
of these milestones and the feeling that
we're not doing things at the right pace
our life expectancy is changing in the
way that we think about a lot of these
things whether it's work or love or
where we live or what we own should be
evolving to why do we have these
timelines in our heads that chart
Milestones as to when things are
supposed to happen in our lives well
it's really funny there just seem to be
a part of us there is one study out of
Stanford that showed that the age that
we think people should do things whether
it's like get your first job or get
married hasn't really changed change
that much so even as we are doing things
later and later people still have this
expectation that like I should be
getting married at the same age that my
parents did or having a kid at the same
age that my parents did how was the
current economy altered that timeline
for a lot of people things like buying a
house Rising home prices interest rates
it's just made a lot of the stuff a lot
harder income inequality there's a lot
of things that have happened to the
economy over decades that have just made
hitting a lot of these Milestones a lot
harder for people student loan debt a
lot of this isn't our fault we're just
in a different financial situation than
our parents or Grandparents were so for
example in the Stanford study that I was
mentioning it found that all generations
coalesced around a few milestones in
your late 20s so they agreed that like
around 26 is the right age to get
married around 27 is the right time to
buy a house and around 28 is the right
moment to start a family but we're not
actually doing those things on that
timeline anymore most of us at least
when people talk about past generations
and hitting milestones we sometimes hear
them say their parents had it so easy or
at least they made it look so easy in a
lot of cases our parents did have it
easier or just different when I was
talking to this professor at Stanford
she made the point if you go back many
decades people graduated from high
school and that was their education and
then they went straight to work and it
made sense to do all of these things in
this order in this kind of compressed
time frame but now our education
opportunities are so much greater the
way we think about relationships are
different what we want from our lives
are different and what we can have is
different because our lifespans are
getting so much longer and middle age is
changing too everything from Botox to
fertility treatments to joint
replacement surgeries have really
evolved over the last few decades and so
you have 60 year olds who are in better
physical shape than their parents were
at 40. I mean we have Martha Stewart on
the cover of Sports Illustrated and she
looks great so I just think kind of how
we think about middle age and what we do
during middle age is really evolving so
if people do focus more on their own
timeline as opposed to comparing
themselves to others how could that
benefit their financial life sure I mean
if we see people like women focusing
more on their careers and education the
more years you save toward retirement
can make a huge difference I mean
there's also a sense that this can get a
little bit risky right if you really
just throw your total timeline to the
win and you're not saving for retirement
at all because what does it matter you
might end up in a tricky situation on
the line at the same time like I said
before middle age is different now maybe
working at a different pace but working
longer wouldn't be the worst thing for
many of us is something that I heard
from the Stanford Professor that having
that kind of like intellectual
engagement in your life and so it's all
about a balancing people have to
prioritize what they want you spoke to
several people who wrestled with this
internal timeline when dealing with
their career what do they tell you
there's a lot of pressure this idea that
I should make a certain amount of money
by the time I turn 30 that I should make
six figures that I should have a certain
job title but what I heard from a lot of
people you reach the Milestone and it
doesn't feel that great you're still
stressed or it doesn't bring that relief
that you thought it's just on to the
next thing and that's when people start
to realize what am I kind of running
toward anyway how much does this
Milestone even matter now earlier you
mentioned life expectancy how does that
fit into this life expectancy he plays a
huge part of this we're living longer
we're living 30 extra years on average
over the last century and so why not
spread out some of these Milestones why
would you want to kind of rush through
all of this just to end up I don't know
retired with your house and everything
at such kind of an earlier marker than
maybe would have been relative to your
parents or your grandparents timeline so
this idea that as the life expectancy is
spreading out shouldn't we also be
matching that with the Cadence of Our
Lives that's Wall Street Journal working
life columnist Rachel feinsick and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]